kitsune and Hellion they're the opposing
fighters of the assassin class in law
breakers based on our time with these
two lethal ladies they're shaping up to
be a couple of the more finesse
combatants of this extreme mobility
arena shooter juggling between their
blades and shotguns can prove
challenging when you first try them out
but it doesn't take long to be an
effective team player especially in
modes like uplink and overcharge you can
check out these modes for yourself in
this video record it from this weekend's
open beta available for free on PC and
PlayStation 4
if this video has convinced you to
preorder or skip lawbreakers give us a
like and subscribe to our Channel and in
a couple weeks we'll have our video
review on both YouTube and GameSpot calm
thanks for watching
[Music]
you have gained the lead
three two one
[Music]
you are still in the lead
three-two-one
sorry sucker
I'm here to shed the blood of my enemies
you are tell in the reeds
[Music]
you are still in the lead
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you are still in the lead
[Music]
the view
our two zones away from winning on I
elation 3/2
[Music]
your ass with a blade you get cut
three point B is a war zone
you win
[Music]
[Applause]